Okay. So I'm not, I'm not like
a big drug guy by any means,
but I think you'll love this story
on this Amazon trip I told you about,
we land on this airstrip
and then this plan we meet,
we get into this village and I'm
like, cool, boats have made it here.
It took the boats five days. We're going
to head up river, right? And are like,
translators, like you can't do that
yet. I'm like, what do you mean?
Like we've spent months planning this.
He's like,
you have to have the Shamans blessing
to go up river. And I'm like, okay,
what does that mean? He's
like, come to the Maloca,
which is the like spiritual house.
So we go to the spiritual house,
we sit around and we talk and we talk
and we talk and it's like hours of not
like asking him to go,
but just like almost like
idle conversation where he's
almost like interviewing
and it's like, well what are you doing?
Where are you going? Where are you from?
And he doesn't really understand
any of this, right? He's like,
he's living in this community. Long
story short, he goes, okay, you can go,
but you have to take this
blessing. And we're like, sure,
we'll whatever you need for us to go.
So he pulls out the snail shell.
I could show you a picture of it.
It's a snail shell with a monkey bone
and the top and a tube worm to close it.
And in the snail shell is this
green powder and he's like,
this is what you need for the blessing.
So he goes around the circle
and threw a monkey bone pipe.
He blows this green stuff. And your
nose is it called the COO? Hey, not,
not say that word that we
heard. I couldn't tell the
name of the pipe. No, no.
The stuff they blow up your nose
is a DMT. It, it's coca leaf. Oh.
Mixed with a bunch of a root and tobacco
I believe. Like altogether. And um,
anyway, so he goes, there's
five of us in my crew.
He goes around the circle and he hits
three guys and they will go, whoa.
My brain feels like I've got chlorine
on the head. You know, whatever.
Loads it into your nose.
Yeah. So it gets really close.
It's got this long tubular monkey bone
pipe and he goes and it just blows it up
into your nose and a hits.
Three of my guys and I'm watching a little
bit nervous cause like I'm very like
standoffish on drugs. Like I know
things affect me very strangely. Anyway,
hits three of my guys, they go whoa, you
know, eyes watering and they're like, wow,
it's a, it's actually a great
feeling. Gets to my turn in the nose.
All of a sudden I feel like I've got acid
on my brain, like chlorine in my head.
I break into the sweat,
my eyes explode and I'm like
wobbling like this. And it,
30 seconds later I'm just curled
over in the fetal position,
just projectile vomiting cannot hold
it together. And uh, Lorenzo, this,
the tribal shaman goes good, good.
And we're like, why is this good?
And he's like, he had a bad spirit
in him. If he had gone up the river,
he would've been killed.
He's just got the bad spirit out.
This is why I had to bless you.
Now you can go.
And I was the only one that had hit
like that out of our five person crew.
Everybody else was like,
oh my brain sore, whatever.
I was literally fetal position,
feverish, puking cray.
And I've never done any drugs like hard
drugs. Like it's just not my thing.
And this thing just hit me like a
ton of bricks. After he said that.
Did you think was there a po,
I mean you're a scientist,
you're a very smart guy,
but was there a part of you that
was like, man, this guy, right? Yes.
That's what's so crazy.
Cause I'm a fucking scientist.
I don't want to believe that.
I don't want to believe fucking jungle
medicine made me not die. But this guy,
here I am. Nobody else fucking affected.
I'm sitting in the fetal position,
puking my brains out and the guys
going, good, now you'll be safe.
And the whole fucking trip, I've got
that in the back of my mind going,
maybe the whole reason nothing's going
wrong is because I just had green fucking
powder bloat up my nose. Whoa.
Yeah. Super Weird. And I,
nothing has ever affected me like that.
I mean curled up puking
and I was shivering. Well,
you trying to make logical
sense out of this. We try.
Was there ever a thought we like maybe
in this extreme environment that's so
utterly different than any other place
in the world that these rules are
different? Absolutely. I mean,
I, I'm sitting there going,
going into it. I'm like,
cool, yeah, I'll do this stupid powder
if it means I can go on my expedition,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not like embracing it.
I'm just like going through the motion
to get my job done as a scientist.
And then I had this experience,
and I'm not saying I was enlightened
or a woken or anything like that,
but all of a sudden I
attributed my success and my
safety in small part to this
green fucking powder blown up my nose
by a sham and throw a monkey bone.
And the thing about it is,
even if that's not true,
if you think it's true and then you wind
up being okay and you have confidence
that you're going to be okay and maybe
you have less anxiety and make better
critical decisions because you think
that everything's going to work out.
Exactly. Exactly. Totally. Because I
was super focused on my mission, uh, we,
we were very, very successful
in what we set out to do. And I,
I feel like because I had that crazy
experience and here's this old little
jungle Indian going,
now you're now you're going to be okay.
I didn't have any anxiety going into
the situation and before that I had no
thought of it ever playing apart. Well
like the mind fuck of the placebo effect.
Right? Totally. We know that that's real.
So there's a some sort of a physical
effect by believing that something works.
Right,
but is there a physical,
is there a change in the way
you interface with reality?
If you believe that you've experienced
some sort of spiritual enrichening and
then some sort of a, some bad spirit
has been released from your body.
Is that possible?
I think so.
I think it changes your own reality
because of your perception of the outside
world. That is a freaky thing for a
scientist to say. Right, right. And,
and this is like, I am a
hardcore academic, I've never
considered spirituality,
religion,
anything.
And I had this just fucking 10 days
ago this crazy experience that has like
changed my mindset on,
uh,
on crazy jungle medicine and
drugs and catching animals,
everything because of this one guy blew
crap up my nose and I puked everywhere.
Wow. Now has this made you want to
experiment with other plant medicines? No.
The only reason I did that is because it
was a necessity to do what I was doing.
It was coming from an expert,
if you will,
a person who saw it as a
necessity to do what I was doing.
And I was under his guidance
to go out and, you know,
pick a mushroom and try it and
have an experience is I don't,
I don't see the benefit in that.
But when someone who lives in that
community embraces that wild jungle says,
this is my home and this is how you do it,
I will absolutely do it.
So you do it like out of
respect. Absolutely. Yeah.